yeah an absolutely tragic uh incident
which unfolded here over the weekend as
Sky News can confirm now the name of the
three people inside the car found just
off this roundabout outside of Cardiff
who died uh on Saturday they are 21 year
old Eve Smith also 21 Darcy Ross and 24
year old Raphael John this is a story
which really began on Friday night uh
Eve Smith Darcy and their Friend Sophie
Russ on were out partying in Newport and
they had then traveled with two men
Raphael Jean one of the deceased and
Shane Lachlan towards fourth call around
30 miles west of Newport to continue at
their party they'd then travel from
there to Cardiff and it is in Cardiff in
the early hours of Saturday morning that
the vehicle they were in was last
spotted on Saturday morning the family
members of all five reported to them
missing to the police and what then
started was a whole weekend of high
profile social media campaigning to try
and awareness of just where these five
young people had ended up none of them
had made any Communications phoned
family or friends or been on their
social media it was in the early hours
of this morning just after midnight that
South Wales police confirmed they had
found the vehicle in question inside the
wooded area and it's understood that
that car had come off the approach here
to the roundabout a busy Main Road and
gone into the Woodland area it is inside
that car they found the five people as I
say three lost their lives 21 year old
Eid Smith uh 21 year old Darcy Ross and
24 year old Raphael John Sophie Russon
who is 20 and Shane Lachlan in his 30s
are both in hospital we understand in a
serious condition there are of course
questions now and questions being asked
amongst the community here not only in
Newport where many of them from but also
in Cardiff as how they could not have
been noticed for nearly 48 hours right
beside a main road outside of Cardiff
that will be a question of course that
police will be focusing on and many of
the locals want answers gwent police has
already referred itself to the police
Watchdog the iopc